今日は外れ社長ですはいというわけで以前
動画でもお知らせしたとおりあの
道
1000万手に入れたんですけどもあのまあ結構入れる考えたりコメント欄とか見て
やっぱ僕らのまあ
いうと1000万円持ってるわけですよ
伊勢守ってその使い道をどうしようか見たいなとだしたんですけれどもあのまあ
いろいろ考えて
まあいろいろ相談しあった結果
[音楽]
1000万円の
使い道が決まりました us
動画コンテスト
f 1風パングランプリで
カツ取った賞金1000万円の使い道は
[音楽]
バズドラ偽前掛けしてみたねー
嘘でいろいろ考えてこう1000万円ポカーンとな口調で会企画をやろうと思ったん
ですけどもまぁ鈴木それよりもっとこうもっと皆さん喜ばせるためにいやそれ以上に
もっと俺自身楽しむためにどういう企画をすればいいかと思ったんですけどあの
1000万円を使って100万円
100万円の企画を
10発
やろうと思います
ああああああ
よっしゃあああごめんねー
それを言いたかっただけあの本盗んだ金以降1000万円だな派手なに住んでもみたい
な気になっていた方が多いと思うんですけど難しかった
新米ルバート使うと最もな方が高思いつかなかったんですけどあの100万円って考え
たらあれ
いろいろできんじゃ
なんか自然万円というか100万円10個って考えたらあれなにか10回ぐらいすげー
面白い9できるんじゃないと思っちゃって
僕まとまんないでもある程度も企画はもうできてます100万円何するかという企画は
4つくらいなかなかこう1個の寄付200万円柄みたいなばみたいな大赤字
企画北たまにしかやんないんで確認かやってますけど
まぁ今回はせっかく手に入れた1000万円なんで見ている皆さんが楽しめるような
企画やってる俺が楽しい企画大炎上寸前尻ゲイの企画
できれば避けたいですけどそれちょっと飛び抜けで企画を10発できればいいかなって
思っておりますしっかり見ちゃんにはもうほどだよ
なんか
というわけであのわかんないんですても100万円超える企画とかもあると思うんです
けどもそうなるとあの10本の企画の数を1本に300はまあすることでちょっと減っ
ちゃったりもするんですけどという感じでちょっと
100万円企画という形でやっていこうと思いますまだ全然いつできるかわかんないん
ですけど見てる皆さんをかめる棄却とかもあると思うのでみんなでパパしてたの
決めればいいなと思っておりますごめん
共有業の大会なんで忙しいと今日よる日本で1動画作ってくれたみんなと打ち上げも
あるんでて釣っというと皆さんに感謝して投票してくださった皆さんに感謝して
楽しいどうぞ
作っていければいいなと思っておりますちっち010000000
使っていこうと思います
じゃん
大会いってきますじゃあ今日は優勝するぞ
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ